former Trump campaign fallacy foreign
policy adviser George papadopolis has
already pled guilty to a criminal
offense now he says he may seek to undo
a deal he made to cooperate with the
Muller investigation Papadopoulos says
now that he was quote framed and the
victim of serious misconduct by
government investigators George
papadopolis joins us to make sure thank
you very much for coming on and I should
just note at the outset that despite
having your life turned upside down
there's no evidence to this day that you
spied for Russia and so I feel for you
in that way but to get specific here
this saga began for you and you met with
the sky professor of myth sued if I'm
even pronouncing his name correctly
where is it seems like we should hear
from him where is he today this man
thanks a lot for hosting me Tucker's so
this is a very important person in this
entire investigation Professor Joseph
Mifsud the man that everyone is looking
at in this picture is allegedly a
Russian agent who had information that
the Russians possessed Hillary Clinton's
emails which they then passed pass along
to me now new information has come out
recently from this man's lawyer and what
his lawyer is telling the world is that
this person Joseph Mifsud was not
working at the behest of Russia when he
was encountering and interacting with
George papadopolis and the Trump
campaign he was under the guidance of
the FBI now this information if it's
true and I have there's no reason to
believe that his lawyer and slandering
his clients and going against the
interests of his own clients if it is
indeed true this information alone up
ends this entire investigation in my
eyes and the narrative of any Russia
conspiracy Russia well that's that's
that's for sure and I wish now I wish we
had an hour to talk we don't we have
about 45 seconds where is this guy white
why isn't he on Capitol Hill explaining
himself I'm going with first of all you
know I would do not receive certain
disculpa Tory evidence that if I had
that information beforehand I probably
would not have pled guilty but that's an
entire other issue that we can talk
about probably in a future time this
person is hiding somewhere in Europe
apparently
his lawyer he's being represented by a
top law firm in London yes dealing with
his negotiations with the special
counsel and apparently he's going to be
coming out public once this
investigation is over so when I meet
saying I was driving wrecked our
political system he'll emerge George and
and your life by the way I hope you'll
come back it was great to talk to you
tonight that's all tantalizing and I
hope we get to the bottom of it soon
thank you